whether you bow down at the altar of the
SMG 11 or cursed the day that the r4
sees a cog was taken away you'll be
happy to hear that today we're counting
down the top ten broken guns in the
history of Rainbow six siege after
riccati Lord hells bases
she finally gonna get dropped does he
find the head in the back - maestro damn
it Chuck now for this one we're going
historical classifying weapons on a
patch by patch basis that means we're
going all the way back to the sniper 19
and we're gonna be dishing out some
personal attacks against those dirty
filthy twitch Mane's who insist they're
only picking her for the utility her
drone offers yeah sure that's like
saying you read playboy just for the
articles all right now let's get on with
our list before it was nerfed in
mid-2016 frost super 90 was one of the
silliest Slammers Siege had ever seen
despite being a semi-automatic shotgun -
the so-called sniper 90 was capable of
[ __ ] on people from absurd distances
making it a staple choice for defenders
looking to do well anything oh my god
three kills with a super nightmare what
is this there is a reason that people
are still traumatized over the damn
thing yeah the shotgun is still pretty
busted
absolutely insane exhibit a Exhibit B
Exhibit C taking the ninth spot on our
list is the old-school version of
Cavanaugh's trusty sidearm Louise on now
look I know people generally think of
calves as a low tier operator and don't
get me wrong she is but prior to its
rework in early 2019 this gun was
downright stupid geez it could destroyed
a whopping 99 damage at close range
making it more akin to a shotgun than a
pistol plus I did virtually no recoil so
it was easy to string shots together all
right now we're getting into the good
stuff coming in at number 8 is nearly
every machine pistol in the game before
their recoil patterns were nerfed in
operation grim sky but more specifically
we're talking about the bearing 9 and
the SMG 12 since the cz 75 actually kind
of got buffed and the SMG 11 was well a
whole other kind of broken the SMG 12
will be getting a swift recoil nerf guys
and you know it's sucks this ego but it
has to be done man this guns [ __ ]
Opie
your nose now prior to August 2018 these
sign arms were essentially better than
the primary weapons they were intended
to supplement needless to say a lot of
people capitalized on how God Tyr they
were coming in at number seven is one of
the most ridiculously oppressive
firearms ever implemented into siege
maestro's alta now we're talking about
the iteration prior to when the guns hip
fire mechanics were realigned with other
LM G's in October of 2018 see before
that the Aldo was an absolute nightmare
Oh Arya oh I don't even mean to kill you
brother but after that well it's
actually still a terror pretty much just
as bad as before that's not to lose all
hope because I found a crazy new
solution we might have had to say
goodbye to hipfire but we can aim in
guys we can aim in with the gun I
figured out if you pushed l2 it actually
aims the gun in and you're just as
accurate as you were before hit firing
this is a beautiful new mechanic that it
just brought into the game and I'm
hoping that gets put to good use
this gun is was and always will be a
hellscape plant going down and Redeemer
will go for two big kills for Redeemer
three oh my goodness puts himself at a
1v1
against shuttle defuser needs to go down
and Redeemer with the clutch coming in
at number 6 is the semi-automatic slug
firing shotgun that we all know and love
kaya and goyós tcsg 12 now shotgun might
be a bit of a stretch because well yeah
I mean it's it's a sniper rifle
[Music]
Oh being that it's essentially a DMR
with breach capabilities the tcsg 12 is
arguably the single most powerful
defender weapon to ever exist in fact
it's pretty much the closest thing siege
has to an auto sniper battle to the
death now a shepherd pops up he sees
water oiled absolutely crush you know oh
my god
ah yes it's time coming in at the
halfway point is perhaps the single most
hated loved and controversial weapon
combo in all of siege the one and only
r4 see with ACOG oh the wool but you
must get lucky just before that they
have the hill right after pat shot off
the Hat shut for that guy long
considered the holy grail of siege guns
nothing has ever slammed quite as hard
as ashes r4c in its heyday favorite gun
definitely are forcing with ACOG if that
was in and say that period the problem
is that the r4c was designed to be the
strongest entry fragging weapon in the
game so once you combined its damage to
raid a fire ratio with a 2.5 times zoom
nothing could stand in its way I mean I
was one of the people who thought you'd
be soft to remove - a girl like I don't
care I mean I thought it was no powerful
basis you're finally gonna get dropped
does he find the head in the back -
maestro damn it Chuck
taking the fourth spot on our list is
the one you've all been waiting for the
416 and mp7 when they had a cogs you
cannot slap an ACOG on both an assault
rifle and one of the fastest and most
accurate SMGs in the game and then hand
them to a couple of three speed
defenders you you just can't
ban on foreign constructor marketing the
crazy thing is that not everyone agreed
never has the Siege community been more
enraged over ubisoft taking something so
blatantly unreasonable out of their game
let's be clear bandit and Yeager's a
cogs were [ __ ] and their removal
vastly increased the competitive
integrity of the game if you disagree
feel free to yell into the ether
Ubisoft seems to really enjoy meeting on
you what's that sir just one pikas jaga
no taking the third spot on our list is
the beautiful awful blatantly ridiculous
instrument of death ever to land in the
hands of siege heads the pre nerf SMG 11
with a cog sorry I'm a dirty [ __ ] now
to this day the SMG 11 remains arguably
the most destructive and versatile
weapon and siege it does a disgusting
amount of damage has the highest rate of
fire of any weapon in the game and
absolutely slams at both short and long
distances 100 start things off as that
croc still get garzooka
the problem is that back in 2016 you
didn't have to be good to use it why
because it has zero recoil and an ACOG
it was beyond stupid alright I snipe
their class
there's another one right why why is
this a thing
why is my secondary or primary weapon
taking the penultimate spot on our list
is every single iteration of twitches f2
ever can we get the yet let me get the F
- Oh F - baby free to kill gun and yes I
know they nerfed the guns recoil
triangle in May 2019 and that made it
slightly less of a laser beam but not
really it's still a nightmare apparently
not loyal the f2 is was and always will
be the single most unreasonably powerful
weapon and siege since launch its
boasted one of the most perennial
estupid damage to rate of fire ratios in
the game and unlike many of its
competitors it has yet to see a real
nerve why it is that siege a single most
easy to use death ray is wielded by a
gadget destroying support operator I
couldn't tell you but it's turned twitch
into a go-to choice for top fraggers
everywhere
what happens when you take a 50 bullet
mag zero recoils zero reload time a
discussing rate of fire throw it all
together and give it to a defender damn
fill-in it one of the most tyrannical
reigns any operator has ever held over
siege I admit that it K edge with a
double countess Eklund mod is kids are
gonna be able to get any will that is
essentially a double he sees math and
what a kill from Kyoto when it comes to
the top spot on our list the first
iteration of Ellis scorpion takes the
cake
it's not even a contest at launch for
SMG was arguably stronger than most
attacker weapons and without a doubt the
single most broken weapon the game has
ever seen from pubs
I have a lot of ammo they have a lot of
ammo to pro-league cancer a Kenny the
first kill of this series the second
kill of vistors the dark L of this
series to this day it remains very
unclear what who be soft was even
thinking when they first put this weapon
into the game fifty bullet like thousand
rpm whatever elegant no recoil it was
ridiculous I'm Ella well guys that's our
list be sure to LIKE the video subscribe
to our Channel
and let us know in the comments if you
think we miss anything so the c70 you've
been on here people are saying it looks
like the new r4c see you next time
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]